A lot of problems around a large-scale
natural disaster
don't go away when organizations come in
and dump funds or food or medicines or
supplies or even help. The organizations
and aid organizations start going away
when the money starts to dry up, those
countries, those communities have to pick
the pieces up and start all over. Our aim
is to create a more informed and
educated practitioner so people who are
going into these affected communities
really know the way to talk to people,
the way to assess the situation, and our
programs are also geared towards
building up those local communities and
their resilience so that the local
responders are capable themselves of
doing such things. We have a lot of
medical residents who come into our
programs every year, some of them based
in the South and Florida, Alabama, places
like that, so domestically, they would be
responding to, you know, Miami, Houston
and Puerto Rico.
There's no greater joy or happiness than
when we get together and play. Today I
worked shift in the ER and it was rather
chaotic and out of control and to come
back to the barn and just play with
really dear friends and visit the right
side of our brains, I think we overload
the left side, try to be analytical. When
we were approached to do this concert
and actually sort of put our little
creative project to a good cause,
particularly one that has to do with our
work at HHI and at the Brigham, and
that's really just a phenomenal
opportunity for all of us.
We've decided as a band that we would pick up all
costs so that all sales will go directly
to Direct Relief International, there's no
overhead, there's no charge, and of course
our, you know, very expensive fee for
playing.